لم نتوقع من الامير هاري وزملائه الا هذه
التعليقات وهي غير من فيض يقول عبد الحق
حماد مسؤول بارز في وزاره الثقافه
والاعلام الافغانيه مطالبا بتحقيقات شامله
في جميع الجرائم الحربيه التي ارتكبتها
القوات الاجنبيه في افغانستان خلال
العشرين سنه الماضيه البريطانيه
بلال كريمي هو الثاني الذي يصف تعليقات
الامير هاري بالهجينه والمسيئه للمملكه
المتحده وخاصه لاسره الامير مضيفا ان
الامير هاري قتل الابرياء من
الافغانستان
صوره صغيره لضرر الشديد الذي الحقته
القوات الغربيه بشعب افغانستان خلال
مهمتهم القتاليه هناك هي تعبر عن تلك
الصوره البشعه التي عاشها الشعب الافغاني
وبالفعل هؤلاء قدير ارتكبوا اكبر مخالفات
قانونيه بسطح افغانستان وكذلك على مستوى
العالم قد طرف الاول يعترف بالجريمه
ثاني يعتبرها وحشيه ضد الانسانيه مطالبا
زملاء الامير هاري بالاعتراف بجرائمهم
التي ارتكبوها خلال مهامهم القتاليه في
افغانستان عبر نادر العربيه كابول